the people who run this country
wouldn't use a word like famine
but that is what the aid agencies are
trying to prevent
for the telltale signs of a human
catastrophe are all around
in south sudan you see it in the eyes
and extended bellies and the
international community
has had to actually
we traveled northeast to the epicenter
of this crisis
in an unstable region called p boar
you know fighting between different
tribes has made it dangerous on the
ground
and unprecedented flooding in south
sudan
has washed down the roads the only way
to pebor
is in one of these
this humanitarian hub is supplied from
the air
but the people who live here can no
longer count on their
second biggest donor the uk has slashed
its aid programs
a key fund worth 120 million pounds a
year
indefinitely delayed we're told
while money supporting rudimentary
health clinics has been
cut this one-year-old korok
was brought in six days ago she was
severely malnourished
and suffering from pneumonia child even
had a very high fever
so we're treating with iv antibiotics
and
some fluids what would have happened if
she hadn't been brought in i cannot
know for certain but i don't think the
child would have made it past
the day of admission or at most two days
if they had not received immediate
medical attention
the number of severe acutely
malnourished children
at this clinic has doubled in the past
year
yet the uk has cut the funding that
supports clinics
nationwide by almost seven million
pounds
people will die said the director of one
ngo
we look at it so unfriendly and so
inhuman
for any country to cut its age at this
particular time
the south sudanese government said it
was notified of the cuts
in a letter but the uk hasn't provided
any details
we ask ourselves as a government what
had gone wrong
between us and and the british
government
because we've felt that it's a time for
them to double the effort to help us
south sudan has lost its way since
achieving independence 10 years ago
the country is poorly governed and
poorly served
by those elected to lead
and its citizens have suffered from near
continuous
political and tribal war
aid organizations have stepped in but
this is not an easy place to work
the people who operate our compound told
us to get out
during our stay in pebor we were
evacuated from our rooms
after a hostile tribe attacked the town
i've got to go through
gates and down alleyways and
through mud the key thing is avoiding
the open road
we reached the base of the un protection
force in pebor
and waited for the trouble to subside
part of the job i guess
anything can happen anytime things are
unpredictable here
[Music]
[Applause]
the next day the men in pibore prepared
themselves
for war they're members of the merle
tribe
and they're organized into age groups
the youngest
going into battle first
[Music]
they were addressed by the chief
administrator who represents the
national government
but he told them to defend their
community
we don't know why my people they are
coming to attack us
okay but yeah i cannot say something
but we are ready to fight you're ready
to fight
peace and sustenance are in short supply
although british officials say south
sudan remains a top priority
despite the impact of pandemic related
cuts
but the un's food program is running out
of money
the uk reducing its contribution by 30
we have had to take some really painful
and difficult decisions
and so in the areas where we are trying
to avert a famine
we are taking from the hungry to give to
the starving
that's never an easy decision to take
but it's one we're forced to take this
year
food will get through if the money's
found with the wfp
now flying in supplies to areas on the
brink of famine
and the lives of millions depend on it
but britain has decided this
humanitarian mission
comes at too high a price john sparks
sky news in south sudan